Dear Fellow Scholars, this is Two Minute Papers
with Károly Zsolnai-Fehér.
Neural networks are amazing at recognizing
objects when being shown an image, and in
some cases, like traffic sign recognition,
their performance can reach superhuman levels.
But as we discussed in the previous episode,
most of these networks have an interesting
property where we can add small changes to
an input photo and have the network misclassify
it to something completely different.
This is called an adversarial attack.
A super effective neural network can be reduced
to something that is less accurate than a
coinflip with a properly crafted adversarial
attack.
So, of course, we may think that neural networks
are much smaller and simpler than the human
brain, and because of that, of course, we
cannot perform such an adversarial attack
on the human vision system...right?
Or is it possible that some of the properties
of machine vision systems can be altered to
fool the human vision?
And now, hold on to your papers, I think you
know what's coming.
This algorithm performs an adversarial attack
on you.
This image depicts a cat.
And this image depicts, uh... a dog?
Surely it's a dog, right?
Well, no.
This is an image of a previous cat plus some
carefully crafted noise that makes it look
like a dog.
This is such a peculiar effect - I am staring
at it, and I know for a fact that this is
not a dog, this is cat plus noise, but I cannot
not see it as a dog.
Wow, this is certainly something that you
don't see every day.
So let's look at what changes were made to
the image.
Clearly, the nose appears to be longer and
thicker, so that's a dog-like feature.
But, it is of utmost importance that we don't
overlook the fact that several cat-specific
features still remain in the image, for instance,
the whiskers are very cat-like.
And despite that, we still see it as a dog.
This is insanity.
The technique works by performing an adversarial
attack against an AI model, and modifying
the noise generator model to better match
the human visual system.
Of course, the noise we have to add depends
on the architecture of the neural network,
and by this I mean the number of layers and
the number of neurons within these layers,
and many other parameters.
However, a key insight of the paper is that
there are still features that are shared between
most architectures.
This means that if we create an attack that
works against 5 different neural network architectures,
it is highly likely that it will also work
on an arbitrary sixth network that we haven't
seen yet.
And it turns out that some of these noise
distributions are also useful against the
human visual system.
Make sure to have a look at the paper, I have
found it to be an easy read, and quite frankly
I am stunned by the result.
It is clear that machine learning research
is progressing at a staggering pace, but I
haven't expected this.
I haven't expected this at all.
If you are enjoying the series, please make
sure to have a look at our Patreon page to
pick up cool perks, like watching these episodes
in early access, or getting your name displayed
in the video description as a key supporter.
Details are available in the video description.
Thanks for watching and for your generous
support, and I'll see you next time!